So the structured knowledge for a presentation called script has six parts to
it. The first part is called entry conditions. These are the conditions
necessary to execute the script. So, for a restaurant script, as an example,
the entry condition might be that there is a customer who is hungry and
the customer has some money. The result refers to the conditions that will
become true, after the script has occurred, after it has taken place. So, for
restaurant script, the result might be that the owner of some restaurant has
more money, the customer has less money, and the customer is now pleased and
is no longer hungry. So the third part of a script is our props. So
the third part of script are called props. Props are the kind of
objects that are involved in the execution of this script so
in case of the restaurant script the props might include tables and
menus and food items and so on. So the fourth part of a script is roles.
These are the agents involved in the execution of the script. As an example in
the restaurant script it might be a customer who goes to a restaurant,
the owner of the restaurant, the waiter or the waitresses in the restaurant, and
so on. The fifth element of a script is a track. Track are variations or
subclasses of a particular script. So for example in case of
the restaurant script we may have tracks for going to a coffee house, or
going to a fast food restaurant, or to a fine dining house. And
finally the sixth element of a script refers to scenes. Scenes are specific
sequence of events that occur during the execution of the script. So in case of
the restaurant script there might be a scene for entering a restaurant. And
a scene for ordering food. And a third scene for accepting the food and so on.
When you put all of the six elements together then you get a complete script.
In the previous lesson we had taken the metaphor of a molecule as a knowledge
representation. That is, knowledge representations that are not small or short
or not atomic, but are molecule in nature, script is a big, large molecule.